I'm making headway with the team and
perhaps I can get through to looook if
we're on neutral ground are you familiar
with anything signs do what they sing
here I would shout out here
I'm not sure the locals will appreciate
French football songs any more than
they'll preciate new eats food look at
your situation and I can't stop
comparing
to my situation when I opened up in my
hometown and Glasgow he got too serious
and though he was scared to come and
then we lost a lot of money and you know
what's the point in keeping your eyes
open if you're losing money and it broke
my heart my hometown was born there
that's what I don't want to see happen
with you you're running the Riviera and
like a three-michelin-star establishment
you've started at such a high level I
don't know if it's such a high level I
mean when you practice with I mean like
your chefs when the practice with you
one days and zero by their own
absolutely
what do you think they're gonna do
here's a good question and ship some
fish I know about you've got to start
with the locals it's not gonna survive
unless that restaurant
so what do the locals want some mustard
or ketchup you have to help yourself you
can't be - nobody Nanga steak sandwich
that's not bad though and when you've
got such good local produce you don't
need to mess with it didn't give my
change I did it no see he's really
Scottish is already my third day but
nothing sinking in surely no it can't
ignore the evidence if it's staring him
in the face this isn't a meal for six
all this is dinner for one at La Riviera
feels like a [ __ ] feast for King
Henry the eighth ah it's quite
interesting when you start from one end
and all the way right to the very end it
helps you to identify where you can just
draw back a little bit and look at the
whole balance of exactly what you're
doing and people have to understand then
is out here to enjoy it
so they have to spend a bit more time on
the table like just say oK we've got two
hour and a half yeah to enjoy it
I couldn't eat all that mm-hmm I I'd
have to stop halfway I think I'd stop
halfway yes I don't know um if I was not
able to eat all this I wouldn't do it
what do we can't get into a stubborn
French brain is that refusing to trust
these ingredients isn't just putting off
his customers it's also a turn-off for
Michelin inspectors